-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
[ Chuckles ] Good one.
-[ Laughs ]
I'm here with Tariq Trotter
from The Roots,
and we are about to play the
classic parlor game charades.
But first, we're going to need
some players.
Joining my team,
she stars in "The Whale,"
which is in theaters right now.
Please welcome Sadie Sink!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi. How you doing?
-I got you. Tariq.
That's my bud right there.
Come on.
We got this, Sadie.
Joining Tariq's team,
she stars in "Funny Girl,"
now playing at Broadway's
August Wilson Theater.
It's Lea Michele!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on. Come on. Come on.
-I'm apologizing.
-Oh, no, no, no. No, no.
-You're apologizing in advance?
-I'm apologizing in advance.
-I think
you're going to be great.
-For defeating them, yes.
-Oh.
Now look, you all know
how to play charades.
We're going to do four rounds.
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
And the fifth round,
it's a showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first.
Everyone can have their seats.
All right, Sadie,
you're over here.
Lea, you're over here.
-Okay.
-Tariq, you can go over there.
Sadie, we got this part.
Come on.
We got this.
Which number, guys?
[ Audience shouts ]
There you go.
One guy yelled two.
That's perfect.
-Aw, man.
-We got this.
[ Laughter ]
-Oof.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's a piano tune.
-All right, no.
Everybody, okay. Here we go.
-Do we get to guess?
-No, you don't guess in this.
All right.
All right, ready?
-Yeah.
A song.
Three words.
First word.
Circle.
[ Laughter ]
Third word.
Baby. Baby.
Circle.
Song.
"Circle of Life."
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
How did you get that?
How did you get --
Wow!
-Circle.
-That's real deal!
-Okay, okay.
-[ Groans ]
-♪ It's the circle of life ♪
-You should've done this.
-Oh, I should've done that.
-I would have gotten it
immediately.
-I should have done that.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Sorry.
Tariq.
-All right.
-Tariq, you're up, bud.
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-[ Shouts ]
-All right. All right.
-Guess I got to go 10 now.
-I've become like Monica
from "Friends."
-Okay. Uh -- Uh...
-Okay, it's a movie.
TV show.
-Right.
-See? [ Groans ]
TV show.
-Um, uh...
-TV.
-Eyes closed. Singing.
Oh...
"Masked Singer"?
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Screams ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That was good!
-Oh, my God.
That's redem--
That was very confident.
-Okay.
-Very confident.
You didn't even say
how many words.
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Aaah!
-I'm sorry. Hey!
-Four?
-Don't yell at --
Don't yell at Sadie Sink.
-[ Laughs ]
-Four.
[ Shouting continues ]
-Wait, that was amazing.
-Is this a thing?
-You didn't even say
how many words.
-Oh.
-All right.
Well, this is good.
I'm feeling this. Movie.
One word.
"Pinocchio"!
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Okay. We got this.
One more. One more.
One more.
-Is it me?
Oh, my gosh.
-One more.
-Okay, I got this.
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Wow.
Three, I'm hearing three.
I'm hearing three.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Ay yi yi.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a -- This is a movie?
Okay.
-A movie!
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-Movie.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-Five words.
First word.
Eye.
Third word.
"I Wanna Dance With Somebody."
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
Oh, my God!
Thank you so much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's ridiculous.
You don't need to do that.
-Eight! Eight!
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh.
All right. This is --
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait. Wait.
This is the showd--
This is the sh--
This is the showdown!
So, we both choose someone from
our teams to go represent us.
I choose you.
-You, you rep.
-Yes.
-Okay, okay.
-You and Tariq,
you guys read the same clue.
-All right.
-And then whoever gets it first.
-Which one?
-Eight! Eight!
[ Laughter ]
-Which one, guys?
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Five. I see a lot of five.
-Okay, okay.
Let's do it.
-All right, all right.
Good luck.
-I'm very nervous.
-Good luck.
-Aw, man.
Okay.
-Okay.
-Wait, hold on. He's going
already. Sadie, he's going.
-It's a song. It's a song.
It's a song.
-Sadie, he's going!
-Oh!
-Three words.
-Song, three words.
-First word.
-Yeah, first word.
-Yawn.
-Tired.
-Tired. Time.
Bed time. Sleeping.
-Sleeping.
-Late night.
-Nighttime. Nighttime.
-Late night talking!
[ Bell dinging ]
Yeeeees!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
♪♪
-I'm sorry!
-Oh, yeah!
Come on now!
-So close.
-My thanks, of course,
to Lea Michele,
Tariq Trotter, Sadie Sink.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The champions!
-Next time.
-When we come back,
we're talking to Lea Michele.
Stick around, everybody.
Oh, my God.